make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so as a result of Netflix
announcing the transformers war for
Cybertron three-part anime series I
guess that's coming out a lot of the
guys have been asking for transformers
content and I got to tell you I'm used
to like Marvel and DC where the
continuities are pretty straightforward
DC is basically rebooted like really two
times ever crisis on Infinite Earths and
then the new 52 well the only real true
times it is line wide rebooted
everything new origins all that kind of
stuff really like like zero hour crisis
and time Infinite Crisis and Final
Crisis were more like cleaning things up
really kind of like organizing and
restructuring would have been done after
crisis on Infinite Earths & Waffles
never rebooted right so it's just been a
singular continuity going forward since
like 1961 and 62 with Fantastic Four and
spider-man and so with transformers I
ended up hitting up a guy named Derek
Ruby right from a Derek Ruby show he's
one of the discord members that we have
and he's really knowledgeable about
transformers and the way he explained it
to me is transformers has like the
Marvel Comics and the IDW comics that
I'm pretty sure there's other comics
that have been made you've got the
cartoon shows you've got the movies and
each one of those are their own
continuities but from what he told me
when it comes to the origin of Cybertron
the tried and true accepted origin for
the most part seems to be what was
covered in transformers issue 61 and 74
back when Marvel was producing them
right so in the 1980s and that point in
time and so what this tells us and the
the details are kind of fuzzy they're
kind of scant here it's not nearly as
easily clear-cut is like what Marvel or
DC is done but what it really seems to
point to is that in the beginning of all
things you simply had the one right this
this one particular being this entity
kind of the Marvel equivalent or the the
Transformers equivalent of like the one
above all from Marvel or DC as presents
but essentially it kind of had good and
evil existing within itself and then
somewhere along the line and we're not
really given details exactly how at
least not within the confines of this
comic ah but somewhere along the line
Unicron was kind of like this
representation of evil and destruction
and consumed essentially everything in
existence or at least assumed it seemed
to be everything in existence except for
a small a small morsel of reality and
that reality essentially coalesced and
then gave birth to a big bang that
literally evolved around Unicron and so
with that also came the creation of
Primus who was essentially going to be a
kind of antithesis to Unicron itself
where Unicron was the agent of chaos and
destruction the Primus was more of an
agent of order and structure and so as a
result of that event
Unicron woke up and came to this
realization that there was all this life
around it and so immediately it ended up
in a conflict with Primus and the idea
was that when this conflict took place
Primus looking to kind of create or kind
of maintain order in structure and
essentially being a champion of life
more or less was essentially losing to
Unicron right and it's one of these
things where it really kind of indicates
the idea that evil usually always
overpowers good I'm not a hundred
percent sure that's true and that's kind
of one of the cool things that I've seen
when it comes to the Transformers is
that at least when you're looking at
this and even the battle between the
Decepticons of the Autobots it's kind of
this sort of timeless war between good
and evil which one actually wins the
Autobots and Decepticons actually sort
of introduced something that wasn't
supposed to be there with regards to
this this whole battle of good and evil
but the end of the day the big takeaway
from this is that with the fighting that
they were having with Primus knowing
that it couldn't actually win right that
it couldn't actually overtake Unicron
because Unicron were simply just that
powerful which again it makes sense
right because when you're talking about
life and death everything dies right if
those guys who remember Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers everything
dies and then everything is reborn again
and I think that's one of the reasons
why if you go and you look at like the
Transformers mythos but one of the
things they say is that the reality is
that Primus and Unicron will always
exist right like good and evil will
always exist I don't know if that's
really true or not but regardless the
way this played out is that with Primus
realizing that it couldn't necessarily
win at this point we jump to
transformers 61 and what we end up
finding out is that understood
recognizing that it couldn't necessarily
win that what Primus did is it
essentially took the conflict between
itself and Unicron to the astral plane
now for those of you guys who are
familiar with like Marvel Comics the
astral plane is not a physical location
right it's not a physical realm when you
go to the astral plane your spirit
essentially leaves your physical body
right you can't take a physical presence
to that that part of existence right
into that dimension and Primus
essentially knew this so we're kind of
left to believe the astral plane in
terms of as it functions in transformers
is Universal across the board right like
an astral plane and transformers is the
astral plane and Marvel is the astral
plane and in DC not in the sense that
they all share the same astral plane but
in the sense that it's form and function
is the same across all these different
properties and so as a result of that
when this took place Prime has made a
gambit he basically took the conflict to
the astral plane essentially removing
their spiritual essences from their
physical bodies and then went back to
the physical realm without their bodies
and then immediately sent their bodies
flying into like these these sort of
metallic
more or less and so what this did is it
is essentially kind of set the the
bedrock or the the baseline level for
what was going to be Cybertron insofar
that Unicron was the first one that
happened to what it is that he could do
right Unicron was the first one when he
was engulfed inside this this giant rock
more or less began to essentially
transform it where I began to basically
modify his body and the way that you
guys are familiar with transformers and
the sense they change into other things
he began doing that and repurposing the
planet and then basically going on this
crusade to basically try to find for our
Primus and destroy Primus but Primus
coming to the realization that so long
as he was essentially awake that Unicron
could locate him track him down destroy
him and then without anybody standing in
his way
wipe out everything in the newly created
universe essentially slumbered but
before doing so what he did is he
created thirteen agents more or less or
13 individuals champions that would
fight on his behalf that instead of
being like Unicron and turning himself
into one giant planet and then attacking
everything there in creating these 13
soldiers more or less he instilled in
each of them what was called the spark
and that was the spark of life that's
what brought them to life and then in
turn he gave them the ability of what
Unicron could do which was to transform
into other things now this is where the
part of the Fallen comes into play and
so forth of the Fallen turned to gifts
Primus and then became an agent of
Unicron but the idea here is that
following that and over time promised
himself developed into Cybertron and
then look to essentially create an army
of individuals who would be able to
stand against Unicron knowing the
thirteen were originally not enough it
would take more and so as the eons past
what you saw was essentially this kind
of proliferation of the Transformers
each of which basically you know
capitalized it and in different ways
changed in comparison to the ones that
came before but the reason why Primus
hadn't really appeared up until at least
this point in a story it was because of
the fact that Primus was essentially
slumbering to again kiba's presents
hidden from Unicron and all the while
kind of monitoring the Transformers
themselves until he believed that they
were capable enough that he could
essentially wake up and then leave them
in a war against Unicron and when the
problem with this is that somewhere
along the line we got the Autobot
Decepticon Civil War that essentially
these soldiers that were created by
Primus ended up in a Civil War
themselves and they were fractured and
so knowing that there was no unified
front against Unicron that there's no
way they could have won I know if I said
unicorn before
I hope I didn't but nonetheless it's a
cool concept right now here again that's
the thing to understand here is from
what I gather when it comes to
transformers and I am by no means nearly
as knowledgeable about transformers as I
am about Marvel I want to get to that
point right like I want to read
transformers and get into it I've kind
of turned into you guys right those of
you guys who are exceedingly
knowledgeable about transformers throw
some information down in the comments
man because like I would have learned
some of this stuff and I'm sure there's
you know the fans and I had out there
want to learn some of this stuff but
like we want to know man it's like now's
your chance
explain comics to comics explain but
explain it to me right lay make it make
sense to me but if this really is the
the generally accepted origin of
Cybertron and transformers did it make
sense right and it's cool like it's it's
pretty interesting like I'm really
diggin the idea of it but again like
what's going on in in recent years and
really for a number of years is the
Transformers always really kind of seem
to get rebooted right so it's always
kind of a reboot a new continuity again
from what Derrick was telling me this is
kind of a generally accepted origin
right now you have a reboot that was
done with transformers in 2019 that's
published published twice monthly right
so is published by weekly and is and
we're only an issue number 19 so like if
you guys are down with that like we can
cover it I don't know you know how it
compares to everything else is going on
and because of some is still in the
early stages given how long transformers
has gone on for it it may be one of
these things where they're still
building stuff up but I'm down like I'm
down to check it out right like I'm down
to covered if you guys want to see it
let me know down in the comments section
if you guys want to see that and I'll
bring it to you right because I love
Marvel and I love DC but I'm kind of
getting tired of just doing Marvel and
DC all the time like I want to do other
stuff like I want to cover some other
stuff besides Marvel in DC I get it's
not going to be the most popular that
it's not gonna get like the most views
ever but at this point I've got enough
other side projects going on I'm not
really worried about the view count on
YouTube on my channel anymore I'm really
more worried about just like doing stuff
I like doing stuff I enjoy that's been
enough time doing clickbait on comments
explained now I'm just doing what I love
the benefits of being a youtuber that's
been around for five years understanding
how YouTube works anyway guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to comments explain it make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the Rob cork if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and if you are knowledgeable about
transformers make sure you drop some
truth bombs some fact bombs down in the
comments section and that will catch you
all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]